if if only if I can only pull myself
onto my front if I can pull myself onto
my front and his legs and his arms are
waving frantically and if I can pull
myself under my front I can get onto the
floor because
[Music]
everybody to see you all
and I'm here to talk a little bit about
our dear friend and devoted
and most beloved
author
Francis Kafka who I'm sure all of you
know quite well probably a lot of him
better than I do
so all I can talk about is my
experience with him how I absorbed a
Kafka within my own being
and how I identified with him
and um
how he meant so much to me when I first
read him I was just so taken aback
because unlike most authors that build
to a climax using a huge amount of
detail and references and and narrative
and experience building up eventually
boiling like a kettle to a climax
France Kafka seems to start he starts
his work with the climax
so so many of his plays and books
stories
begin with the climax so
it's like in the trial when he said
somebody must have been lying about
Joseph K but without having done
anything wrong he was arrested one fine
morning
the landlady is cooked whom only brought
his breakfast at eight o'clock
failed to appear that had never happened
before
okay waited a moment longer
people opposite were staring at him with
distinct curiosity
see starts with a climax before
before the people the detectives the
police gradually encircle him same with
metamosis
Greg and Sam's
woke
from a night of uneasy dreams
and found himself transformed in his bed
into
a gigantic insect
his numerous legs which were bitterly
thin
compared to the rest of his bulk
waved helplessly before him
our
what's happened to me
he thought was no dream
he looked at the alarm clock ticking on
the chest
half past six in the hands were quietly
moving on
oh
Gregor said a voice
that gentle voice
it was his mother's
the devotion of the mother to son is so
is strong and kafka's work
very very strong obviously particularly
more metamorphosis
when his mother really is here only she
nourishes him suckers him defends him
protects him
stands up for him
his mother is everything in the world to
him
he relies on his mother and he also
realized on his sister Greta his lovely
sister Greta who he is paying from his
work to go to the academy
in whatever it is Vienna Prague studying
the violin
and yet Frank Kafka or
as he is the beetle like the samsa I've
been working every day
going to work packing his samples in his
bag
traveling on the train on the bus
day after day day after day to earn
enough money to pay for Greta his
sister's violin lessons and keeping the
family because his father
Mr Sampson
or in real life his real father Herman
Sansa
was a very gritty Gravelly man he was a
very tough man
he had little little kind of small tiny
wholesale business and the square in
front of Prague
the Prague Cathedral
where he sold Bricker bracken's Nick
nacks and and bits of
kind of kitchen pots and cups and sauces
and all sorts of little things and he
was a hard worker he was a hard
dedicated worker than he he never spared
himself never took a day off and he was
tough he was strong and he saw in Frank
Kafka
he saw this week
febrile delicate sensitive curious is
this my this my son it is this curious
sensitive
overweeming oh over careful so nervous
just sitting in his little room writing
poetry this my son oh God he would like
to associate with other writers and
artists and sensitive people and
Herman
wandered him of course
to be part of the business
the part of us they call part of the
gift
so he could work and support his father
be a mensch work with him his father
could be proud of him could introduce
him
and instead
he seems to be producing this rather
ungainly
highly
sensitive curious bizarre
creatures stays in his little room
Reading
omnivorously Writing endlessly
and he thinks what what is this stuff
he's writing I mean well what is
peculiar what is this putrid things he's
writing is horrible and one day
uh Franz Kafka wrote a letter to his dad
he wanted to show his dad
what he felt he wanted to be to Bear
himself to be naked and it's something
we very rarely do in front of our
fathers
I never spoke to my father his entire
life
I don't think I exchanged more than one
or two sentences at a time
throughout his entire life
except at the end at the very end
and so he funded to write a letter to
explain to divulge to in a way expiate
to expel what he was feeling and he said
to his father I know I know I know I
disappoint you I know you're
disappointed in me I know that I don't
fulfill your expectations and I know
that somehow in your eyes and somehow in
your eyes you see me as some kind of
insect you have no moral respect for me
than you would for an insect that you
crush
he dare to say this dare to say this to
his father his father couldn't
understand this that's how it was
bizarre it was just just in fathomable
but he had to bear this letter he had to
tell and this letter perhaps
was the jam
that may have led
to him writing one of the most notorious
most fantastic most bizarre most
surrealistic most uncanny most dreamlike
stories
that has ever been written
and yet writing it with such forensic
detail with such care every single blade
of grass is counted every little gem
every crumb as he describes and he wakes
up in the morning and you can see the
segments of his belly and on the
segments are little spots and neither
spots is a kind of shell and outside the
shell is a kind of rib cage and outside
this ribcage a rather little tiny mini
spots and the legs are kind of too small
for his body and he's he's laying there
on his back and he thinks himself oh oh
oh oh if if only if I can only pull
myself onto my front if I can pull
myself onto my front and his legs and
his arms are waving frantically and if I
can pull myself onto my front I can get
onto the floor because
the family are alarmed
they're saying Gregor
Gregor it's half of six
already break isn't it time to get up
Vega regret has a sister
greca Greco what's wrong what's wrong
Gregory are you ill are you needing
something
each pleading each knocking on the door
each rapping on the door as if the door
would be the signal the morse code to
him opening the door revealing himself
he must reveal himself because why has
he suddenly stayed in his room not
getting up and he has never done this in
years not in all the years nor the days
nor the nights nor the weeks know the
months never he has never stayed in his
room he has never refused to get up
never never never so what
what could be going on
McGregor knows only if he could he's on
the bed
he's on the bed and his legs
are waving frantically he's trying
trying to make sense of them trying to
find some some coordination
and then he can't he's finding it
difficult but he rocks ah he rocks he
has control of his Rocky and he rocks
and rocks and then suddenly slides off
the bed Bang
and they hear that oh
Gregor
Gregor are you all right
you're right
now
the reason they can't get in
it's because he has locked the door
he has locked the door in his own
bedroom naive and I even with my my
father
I never locked the door
but he's locked the door in his own
bedroom
as if he was living with aliens as if he
was living with Waters as if he was
living with sadistic SS he has locked
the door
so how can he get in they can't get in
they're trapped they're absolutely
as we say
I'm trying to think of the word in
German
besides gifts to send it they are
astonished they can't get in and so the
Gregor thinks the only way
is for me to get onto the floor I'll
crawl along the floor and then I'll
crawl up I'll crawl up the door and then
if I crawl up the door slowly slowly
because he has sticky pads here and
these sticky pads enable him to hold on
and the sticky pads he reaches the key
opens his jaw wide
thousands it on the key and they go
you
think
it hurts his jaw my God
or if they smear that is painful
but still he keeps on keeps on then the
key
opens
the key snaps back
and then
the door
slowly
opens
and maybe Greta just pulls it a little
bit more
and they see
this poor thing has fallen back on his
little feet
with a bit of gooey stuff dripping out
of his jaw
and that's what they say
that's what they say
they see a huge unbelievable
monstrous
insects
huge is this
sickening beyond belief
is beyond belief
they're frozen
now
what is brilliant about France Kafka is
that he doesn't think in a linear
fashion he doesn't think in a
naturalistic or realistic fashion
reality to him is merely
merely if you like
the outer layer merely the skin realism
is merely the kind of I wish there was
the right word for it
but it's somehow the trivial
kind of
outer husk of
real life it's just what we do we eat we
drink we get married we jump in the bars
we sit at the table eating we we talk we
discuss we write letters We complain
mistake we have babies
realism and
I've noticed that in spite
of
England and Stephen Scotland having some
very skilled writers very skilled
dramatists and novelists Poets
they are
in a way at the end of that spectrum of
realism
where they feel if they put a character
on stage that is real that it will touch
us and we will somehow feel for them so
if they put do something like
anything of any play
I'm trying to think of something maybe
like a usual new play Long Day's Journey
Into Night the two sons are frustrated
they have Ambitions and dreams but they
can't be fulfilled
because the father maybe has a into
self-obsessed with his own life
as an actor he was a great actor the
Elder O'Neill
and the sons are frustrated one wants to
be in the Navy he talks about that and
the wife is a drunkard and she's always
drinking the cover-up a kind of she has
some problem pulses she's taking pills
every day and she's getting hooked on
these pills so this is what we see which
is what we see on the stage he says the
banality of the outer skin but what
someone like after
but someone like even as a painter Dolly
with someone like Stravinsky as someone
like even her own beautiful Dylan Thomas
or like her own JoJo
penetrates beneath the skin it is
surreal it is a dream we investigate our
inner lives our unconscious life those
dreams we have at night which don't
quite make sense
because time and space have congealed
twisted
so
there is no reality we discuss
and our works the inner mind the
torments and what are they
they are somehow Illustrated in dreams
symbolically because the dream wants to
teach us something
so it symbolizes the ACT
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas